Je n'étais qu'un enfant quand j'ai quitté la Terre,
je n'avais aucune idée de ce que l'univers
me
réservait, je fais face à une menace imparable,
vous êtes notre dernière chance, je suppose que nous sommes
coincés ensemble, partenaires, me dites-vous
que les 12 milliards de personnes définitives sont
entre les mains d'un voleur deux voyous
meurtrier panamanie
ce n'est peut-être pas la meilleure idée de ne pas rester en
attente car le mal anéantit des milliards
de vies innocentes
pourquoi risqueriez-vous votre vie pour cela
parce qu'en ce moment Mike nous donne une
chance
si nous ne protégeons pas le  galaxie
qui va qui suivra ton exemple
oh ouais
ça va faire mal
j'ai un plan
c'est un faux rire c'est un vrai
groupe totalement faux
merci c'est
quoi c'est un Bob et tu le laisses
traîner j'allais le mettre dans une boîte
quoi de  une boîte va faire tu veux juste
aspirer la joie de tout